Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning. I know it's
raining and I know you guys are tired.
Uh, we're gonna try that one more time
'cause uh, I frankly, I've got 30 more minutes and,
and that's a awful way to start.
Let's go. Good morning. Yeah.
See now the, the wet feet are paying off, aren't they? Yeah.
Uh, I'm Phil Ali.
I'm the pastor of discipleship and community,
and God called me to Henderson Hills
to help create a culture of discipleship.
And I can't think of a better place to serve.
I'm honored to serve you here.
And so I wanna start by saying thank you to Pastor John,
our lead teaching pastor
and our elders for giving me the opportunity, the privilege
and honor of addressing you about Psalm 71.
So, uh, turning your Bibles to Psalm 71.
While you're doing that, uh, we're gonna multitask here.
How many by raise of hand would say
that you've ever tried something and failed miserably?
Go ahead. I see that hand. I see that hand.
Uh, that's my, um, Billy Graham.
If you came in a bus, the bus will wait.
We've all made mistakes
and we've all, even if they're accidental,
we've just blown it.
And what happens then, as a result, is
that we have this fear of failure
and mistakes that cause us
to hold back when God is calling us
somewhere to do something.
And how many of you have,
and you don't have to raise your hand on this one, how many
of you secretly or regretfully thought if I only,
or if I never, or, or why didn't I
or if I had only, well, I've got really good news
for you today in Psalm 71.
What if you could start and stay
and finish strong?
And that's, uh, that's exactly
where this passage is taking us today.
Uh, I wanna start with a story.
I'm gonna only tell one story today,
but it's gonna come in three spots.
It was February, 2022.
And a, an ice storm had just blown through North Dallas.
In fact, it came all the way through.
And you guys, many of you got the, the day off,
if not the week off.
And so I was sitting at home
and I was sitting in my recliner and I had my pajamas on.
I had a cup of coffee. I just finished my quiet time.
I was thinking, man, I'm so sorry for this ice,
but sure is nice to have a day off.
And, and then I hear this knock, knock, knock,
knock on the drywall,
and I immediately know what's happened.
And, uh, best case scenario, I went to my wife
and I said, Hey Carol, were you knocking on the drywall?
For some reason she said, no.
And some of you don't know this, but my mother, she's 89
and she's had dementia, lived with us
for the last eight years.
And, uh, it was her knocking on the wall.
And when I heard her knocking on the wall, I knew
that she had fallen and broken her hip.
And so I went into her room
and sure enough, she was laying on the floor.
And I said, mom, what happened? She goes, I don't know.
And I said, can you get up?
And she goes, no, I can't get up.
And so, uh, I had to call the, uh, ambulance.
Uh, what pastors normally do is they, they network
with one another and they get a good deal.
And so, uh, we know which hospital we're going to
and we know how we're gonna get there.
Great big ambulance.
I remember one of the eight, uh, one
of the ambulance guys falling down because it was icy.
And, and they're trying to get
my mom down and he falls down.
We get into this thing
and we're, we're driving down the North Dallas hallway.
And at one point we kind of started sliding this way
and I was thinking, oh great.
My mom's got a broken hip. We're on an icy road.
I'm gonna be in an accident on North Delta. Holy.
And that's what happens to us when we're in the middle
of a storm, we begin to think in terms
of worst case scenarios
and we forget that we have a God who's in charge.
And so, uh, I get to the er
and of course there's very few people there
because the city's literally shut down.
And I know my mom's hip is broken.
And we tried to get a doctor there.
And while we're getting ready for a doctor to arrive to,
to give us some instructions, I began
to have a conversation with the Lord.
And I said, God, you know her.
And you know, she gave her life for me.
And my brother, my dad, she, she served selflessly.
She, uh, she cared
for my brother when he had multiple sclerosis for 16 years.
And now she's got dementia
and she's fallen and broken her hip.
God, what are you trying to do here?
And I think it's okay to ask God questions. He's big enough.
This is a psalm of lament.
Many of the lament psalms ask similar questions.
And so we're gonna come back to that story in a minute.
But, but at every stage in life, there are storms that come.
Teenage students, uh, seemingly I always preach right
before school's about to get started.
And so are you excited about getting back to school
and fitting in and, uh, facing exclusion or isolation?
What about the anxieties
and pressures of finishing with a high GPA so
that you can have a college of your choice?
And what about single young adults?
Are you concerned about finding a fulfilling calling
and maybe, um, serving in a way
that you didn't feel like you were in a dead end job?
And what if you could start and stay
and finish strong, married, young adults?
Are you facing any financial pressures?
Are you managing student loans and rent
and mortgage payments and credit card debt?
Do you have any anxiety about maybe getting your bills paid
from month to month?
You worry about losing a job?
What if you could start and stay
and finish strong median age adults?
Are you ever worried about providing for your family
or do you worry about being able to give the kind of energy
and passion to your marriage
to make it work the way it should?
What about worrying about losing your job
or not being able to advance in your career
or not being able to support yourself in retirement?
Which brings us to senior adults.
This psalm is written from the perspective
of a senior adult man.
I can't for the life of me figure out why they give it
to me, but this psalm is recorded
in a unique voice of someone who's growing older,
someone whose capacities mental and physical
and relational capacities are beginning to to weaken.
And so with this declining health and loss of independence
and maybe the death of a spouse,
what if retirement just gives you more time for worry
and anxiety and boredom and loneliness
and discouragement and frustration?
What if you could start strong and stay strong
and finish strong?
Well, the psalmist and Psalm 71 gives us an encouraging word
from a lifetime of experience.
And we know because we live in a fallen world that life
as we know it is a test of our faith.
In Jesus said in John 1633, I've said these things to you
that in me, you might have peace in the world,
you will have tribulation that can also be, uh,
interpreted trouble or pressure or affliction or distress.
But take hearts is the amen moment. Prepare, but take heart.
I have overcome the world.
So before we get started, I wanna read
to you a beautiful passage from
Gerald Wilson about the Psalms.
Picture yourself as one of a crowd packed together
with thousands of others, shoulder
to shoulder, elbow to elbow.
Experiencing this as one common event there
in the air is a sense of excitement and anticipation.
The sense of common purpose
and experience draws the whole crowd together.
As you respond to the events of the moment in this setting,
you discover that your individual response becomes a part
of something larger just outside yourself as you react
to community of the joys and the sorrows and the victories
and defeats that are acted out before you.
Now as you've come to your senses, you're beginning
to understand what reading of the book
of Psalms is all about For whatever,
whenever we crack open this biblical book
and read from its collection of 150 songs,
whenever we allow ourselves
to truly be immersed in the world they bring to life,
we're taking our stand with a huge crowd of the faithful
who have sung these psalms throughout the generations.
Whenever you sing them or pray them, you're praying
and singing and reading alongside a huge crowd
of faithful witnesses.
Throughout the ages, the words
that you speak have been spoken thousands, even millions
of times before in Hebrew, in Greek, in Latin, in English,
and a myriad of other languages.
As you read or pray off to your right stands, Moses
and David and Solomon.
And to your left is Jesus and Peter and Paul.
And behind you are Saint Augustine and Luther and Calvin.
If you can catch a glimpse
of this far-flung spiritual community of believers
and take your place within it, then you can begin
to understand why we still sing and pray
and read the book of Psalms.
You're taking a stand with believers, past, present,
and future who together sing the songs of celebration
of a steadfast love of God.
And with that, we start Psalm 71, how do you start
and stay and finish strong?
First you make God your home,
make God your home 71, 1 in you.
Oh Lord, I take refuge
that word refuge can be also interpreted.
Shelter or dwelling place.
You make God your home because he is your rescuer.
Look at verse two, verse one in you, oh Lord, I take refuge.
Let me never be put to shame. Verse two.
And, and in your righteousness might be the hinge
of the entire Psalm in your righteousness.
Deliver me and rescue me.
Incline your ear to me and save me.
So God is our refuge and God is our rescue.
But this rescue is based upon his righteousness.
It's not anything the psalmist has done.
It's not in the psalmist circumstances
and it's not in the opinions of others.
And what they think of the psalmist rescue is found in God's
righteousness alone.
Another way to say that is God's rescue is the function
of his righteousness.
And that's why we go to him and make him our home.
He is our rock of refuge. Look at verse three.
Be to me a rock of refuge in which I may continually come.
You've given the command to save me, and you are my rock
and my fortress rescue me, oh my God, from the hand
of the wicked, from the grass of the unjust
and the cruel man.
See, God was the strong
and permanent home for this psalmist's soul.
A place where he could continually come and find safety
and strength and protection.
A storm shelter, that's what preaches in Oklahoma.
By the way, anytime he says, we used to say Fredy hole,
but then somehow it, it got uncool.
I can't imagine a strong storm.
Shelter a fortress if you will make God your home.
Number two, make God your hope.
Look at verses five through eight.
If you wanna start and stay
and finish strong, make God your hope for you.
Oh Lord, are my hope, my trust.
You have to believe that God is trustworthy.
And number two, you have
to believe God is faithful my trust, oh Lord,
from my youth upon you.
I've learned from before my birth you
who took me from my mother's womb.
My praise is continually of you.
And so he is faithful and I can trust that.
And there is where I put my hope. Look at verse seven.
This is, this is a stunning verse for I have been
as important to many for you are my strong refuge.
We have to explain that phrase as important.
In the King James. It says a wonder in the NASB,
it says as a marvel.
And what's happening here is
because of the things that are happening in the psalmist's
life, 'cause of his weakening
and his frailty, he's beginning to get a reputation
as someone who can't be trusted as a leader.
Any law. I mean, he's, he can't lead, he can't.
Uh, it's at, at the end of your life as you begin to
to suffer the, the, the effects of aging,
then he's getting a reputation for his pain and suffering.
And people were shocked at the troubles
this old man was facing.
So much so that they thought
that perhaps God had abandoned him.
But even in his old age.
And, and guys, uh, as I studied this,
this just filled me with hope.
Even in his old age.
He wanted, he still wanted to be an example of how to live.
And he wasn't going to be defined by
what people thought of him.
And he understood that God was his strong refuge,
his dwelling place, his shelter, his home.
And so his strong refuge was a strong enough
place to find safety.
And that's why he would continually go back.
My mouth look, says in verse eight, my mouth is filled
with your praise, with your glory all the day.
Everybody say all the day. All the day.
Now, the reason I'm asking you to do that week,
by the way, I'm gonna try it again.
Um, the reason I'm asking you is it in this verse three
times, he goes back to that phrase, which reminds us
that we have to continually go back
all the day, all the day.
So when I say how long I want you to say
all the day, how long?
All the day. So that's, that's
what it means when he says I've become a port in, is
that people have seen me
and they wonder, has God abandoned him?
And that's why God in his hope gives me a hopeful voice.
My mouth is filled with praise of your glory. How long?
All the day, let me ask you a question,
which is the best description for your voice right now?
Has it been silenced?
Is it characterized by whining, complaining,
blaming,
crying, or praising?
So how do you star and stay and finish strong?
You make God your home.
You make God your hope and you make God your help.
Look at verse nine. Do not cast me off in time of old age.
Forsake me. Not when my strength is spent
for my enemies speak concerning me.
Those who watch for my life consulting together
and say God has forsaken him, pursue
and seize him for there is none to deliver him.
There's two reasons to lose hope,
but two even better reasons to seek help.
And one is, God, don't forsake me.
Remember, this is what Jesus said on the cross.
He's thinking, I'm getting old.
I'm being attacked by those who come around me.
I need your help. But number two, God,
don't be far away from me.
See as it is the righteousness that provides the rescue,
it's God's presence that provides the power.
Verse 12, may God your hope, oh God, do not be far from me.
Oh my God, make haste to help me.
May my accusers be put to shame
and consumed with scorn and disgrace.
May they be covered. Those who seek my hurt, God,
don't be far away from me.
Help me quickly. Help me completely for I face danger.
And I I I refuse to not be anchored
to you when the storm winds blow rather than weakening his
faith, these trials are strengthening his faith.
So I'm sitting in the ER with my mom
and it's a horrible ice storm and there's no doctors there.
And while we're waiting for a doctor to come
to evaluate the x-rays, they've already taken,
I have eight hours in the ER with my mom and she's sedated.
And so she gets to sleep and I just have to sit there.
And I wasn't prepared.
I did take my phone and I look on my phone
and I get a text from my daughter
and she doesn't know I'm sitting in the ER
with her grandmother.
And it's just a simple little link
and it says, uh, hhbc.com jobs.
I'm not looking, I'm at a great church in Texas.
Uh, I'm doing, uh, exactly
what I believe God is wanting me to do.
Uh, but God somehow gets my attention that day
and I've got nothing but time.
And I look at this website
and uh, I see the very first
thing is the mission and vision.
We equip one another to love Jesus and live sin.
I thought that's, that's a great vision
and that's a great mission.
So I go on to the mission statement
and it says that we are, uh, creating a culture, a, a, uh,
to become a hub of discipleship.
And then I look over at the job description
and it's for the pastor of discipleship and community.
And they're like, they want a pastor of discipleship
to help them accomplish the mission of making disciples.
I dunno, what's this culture all about?
So I start reading these core values
and each time I read a core value, I begin to think more
and more, you know what, that sounds like a great place
to serve Jesus.
And so for the first time I'm thinking, what if God
is opening a door for me to go to Edmond
to serve at a church that wants to make disciples?
It just happens to be a few miles
away from my granddaughters.
So, you know, I mean that's a part of the equation.
I get to see my daughter, my son lives in Oklahoma City.
It's gonna be easier to be closer to them.
How do you start and stay strong and finish strong?
Will you? Number four, you make God your hope.
Now, some of you're thinking, oh, that's too bad.
The old man forgot. He's already said hope.
As a matter of fact, when I submitted my notes,
pastor John said, Hey, did you mean to say hope twice?
Just so you know he's looking out for you.
But the text drives this. Let's read it in verse 14.
But I will hope continually, continually means
that I gotta go back for more hope as the world is,
I feel these storms blow.
I feel the darkness come around,
but I need you to know that continually and increasingly
and emphatically sometimes each day, each hour, each minute,
each breath and each thought, I have
to come back again for hope.
And this psalmist expresses this hope, this continual,
this increasing emphatic hope in a sovereign God
that he can be trusted.
And his praise tells us that the character of God
and the acts of God serve as the basis of hope,
as the reason for his praise.
How do you make God your hope?
While I will hope continually. Verse 15.
And my mouth will tell of your righteous acts,
of your deeds of salvation.
How long all the day
for their number is past my knowledge,
what I'm learning in my sixties?
Yes, it's true teenagers, someone lives that long,
that the longer you live, the lower your trials,
the more your praises must increase as well.
That's how you make God your hope.
Look at verse 16, there's three ways to do it.
And one is by proclaiming him with the mighty deeds
of the Lord, I will come and I'll
remind them of your righteousness.
Yours alone, oh God, from my youth, you've taught me
and I still proclaim your wondrous deeds.
So even in my old age
and gray hairs, oh God, do not forsake me
until I proclaim your might to another generation.
Your power to all who come. I proclaim your mighty deeds.
I proclaim your righteousness. I proclaim your power.
This man can't keep quiet about God's greatness.
He proclaimed that God could be trusted
to take wrong things and make them right.
And this is what I love about old age.
And there's not a ton of things, but this is one of them.
He can look back and say, you know what?
God has been trustworthy since my youth.
God is trustworthy right now, whatever age I am,
and God will be trustworthy even
until my old age in gray hair.
So you do it by proclaiming him
and then you do it by pursuing him.
Verse 19, your righteousness,
oh God reaches the high heavens, you've done great things.
Oh God, great question. It's a rhetorical question.
You don't have to answer this question. It answers itself.
Oh God, who is like you?
You've made me see many troubles and calamities,
and you revive me again from the depths of the earth,
you will bring me up again.
So you revive me, you rise me in verse 21, you restore me,
you'll increase my greatness and comfort me again.
Number five, how do you start strong
and stay strong and finish strong?
You don't just make God your home and your hope
and your help, you make God your hymn.
Now a hymn is a song of praise.
By the way, those of us with gray hairs, we know
what the hymns are and we were raised on the hymns.
And that's the only words that we can remember
to the songs that we sing.
And so we really like the hymns.
But but hymn means more than just
what you read in the Baptist hymnal.
Hymn means any song of praise, any anthem
that describes his greatness.
Look what it says in verse 22.
I will also praise with a harp for your faithfulness.
So I celebrate your faithfulness with a harp.
Oh my God, I will sing praises to you with a liar.
Oh holy one of Israel, another stringed instrument.
I celebrate his holiness with a liar.
And then the rest of it is done with his,
uh, his best instrument.
And that is with his mouth, with my lips will shout
for joy when I sing praises to you, my soul also,
which you have redeemed.
And my talk will come
and my tongue will talk of your righteous help.
How long, all day long where they've been put to shame
and disappointed those who sought to do me hurt.
So with shouts of joy
and with shouts of praise, with my lips, with my tongue,
with my, with my mouth, I will praise him.
So we we pursue him and we proclaim him and we praise him.
Well, now we come to the application part of the service.
I can't believe that we were able to get
through 22 verses in 22 minutes and 39 seconds.
This is working out just perfect.
I don't know if you were here that day,
but two years ago in May, I was sitting right here
and uh, pastor John was sitting right here.
And the question was, this guy wants to be our pastor
of discipleship and community.
What do we think about that? Now,
when you are 62 years old
and you're sitting in front of a group
of young people like this and you're thinking to themselves,
they're probably thinking, why is grandpa here?
We wanna be disciple makers.
We we don't wanna be fill in the blank.
And so there, there's this moment in the middle
of life's choices where you have this crisis of belief
and you just have to say, God, I have been able
to trust you, then I'm able to trust you now
and I'll be able to trust you in the future.
And so I remember thinking, God,
are you calling me to serve here?
Well then you're gonna have to convince these people
that I'm the right God.
And then I'm asking, God, can you use me to help this church
discover a disciple making culture?
And, and frankly, I can't think
of a better calling in life as a 64-year-old man
with gray hair to say, when I was a junior high boy, that's
what they used to call middle schoolers.
When I was a junior high boy,
my pa my youth pastor asked me if I wanted
to be a part of an discipleship group.
And now 50 years later, I get to say
to the junior high boys, the middle schoolers, if you will,
Hey, this is a big deal.
Jesus commanded that we do this.
Will you be obedient to this?
And today I'm honored to tell you that you can,
regardless of the life sta stage you're in,
you can start strong and stay strong and finish strong.
The answer is yes you can.
If you make God your home, your refuge, your dwelling place,
your strong shelter, if you make God your hope,
he is trustworthy and faithful all the day.
How long all the day if you make God your help,
God's presence is the answer and he is always near.
If you make God your hope, I will praise him.
I will proclaim Him. I will pursue him.
And if you make God your hymn, he will give you a song
and you will celebrate him as you sing of his righteousness
and his holiness church.
You can, you can, you can.
You also can continue to struggle.
You can continue to stagger on through life, homeless
with no safety, no shelter exposed
and in danger, helpless on your own.
I don't need any help from anybody
and hopeless with no song to sing, don't do it.
Choose you this day who you will serve
as from me and my house.
We will serve the Lord.
Our circumstances are not the right way
to assess whether our lives have value
and service to the Lord.
The opinions of others are not a reliable measurement
of whether our value to the Lord is
spent faithfully in obedience and service to him.
Listen to me. The gospel
of Jesus Christ is the only right way
and the only reliable way to measure the value of our lives.
What did he say in Romans five, eight?
But God demonstrated his love for us in this
and that while we were still sinners, Christ died for us.
He showed us how much he loved us
when Christ was on the cross.
He was the example of ultimate victory by all measurements.
The cross of Christ, the circumstances
and the opinions of the passersby could only be described
as a miserable failure, A mocking crown of thorns,
soldiers spitting on and beating on our Jesus, hanging,
humiliated while pastors by hurled insults hands
and feet nailed to the cross.
Yet think about how the suffering servant could die, such
as disgusting criminal's, death on the cross and then
and then and then rise
to become the conquering messiah in the power
of a resurrected life.
For all who believe the gospel
of Jesus Christ is the only way to measure our lives.
At any stage in life, we need to follow God's evaluation
of our lives and overcome the many lying voices
that seek to keep us quiet.
If I'd only, if I never, why didn't I?
If I only had, these lying voices
must be obliterated from our souls.
And we must believe
with the psalmists confidence in your righteousness,
deliver me and rescue me.
Be to me as a rock of refuge
to which I may continually come for you.
Oh Lord, are my hope, my trust, my mouth is filled
with your praise, with your glory.
How long all the day, oh God,
don't be far from me.
I will hope continually and I will praise you yet more
and more and I will remind them of your righteousness.
Yours alone. For you have done great things.
Oh God, who is like you? My lips were shout for joy.
When I sing praises to you, the gospel
of Jesus Christ is the only right way
to reliably measure the value of our lives.
That fact and that fact alone is how you start strong
and stay strong and finish strong.